من القاهره الفنان عبود خواجه يسعد صباحك
وصباحك سعيد دائما
صباح الخير عليكم وعلى مشاهدينا العربيه
وان شاء الله نكون ضيوف خفيفين وانت خفيف
على القلب والروح دائما اكبرك اذا قلت لك
اني انا كنت اسمعك من ايام الاشرطه
الكاسيت اعتقد كانت هي حفله
الطلبه اليمنيين في الكويت ما ادري عاد اي
سنه كنت هناك وكنت لسه صغير يعني شباب
اكثر من الشباب وما زلت شباب
انا شايب ما كبرتني ابدا الله يحفظك
خليني اسال عبود خواجه اختلف الفن اليمني
اليوم عما كان عليه في الثمانينات
والتسعينات على الاقل
اكيد الفن في كل مكان اختلف
اختلف في الفكر الشعراء فكر الالحان فكر
كل شيء اختلف تماما
طويله
مؤخرا شو سبب غيابك وحرمان جمهورك يعني من
صوتك الجميل
انا غبت الاسباب خاصه وهي الخلافه مع
الحكومه اليمنيه
وتقريبا من 2007 وانا غايب او مشرد من
دوله الى دوله الى دوله ولكن الحمد لله
لان الامور طيبه وكل شيء
راجع بقوه خاصه انه اليوم انت قلتها الان
قبل شوي بانه حتى التقبل للناس
للفن اليمني مختلف باعتبار انه اليوم في
اغاني يمنيه وصلت الى العربيه والعالميه
باختلاف المفرده واللحن
ما اعتقد الامر يعني
الفن في كل مكان يتجدد
وفي الغث وفي السميد ما زال يعني موجود
ولكن دائما
المستمع دائما هو من يقيم الشيء الجميل
ويعطيه مكانته واعتقد ان احنا ان شاء الله
يعني عدنا بعد فتره من الاغاني كذا
السريعه الان عدنا الى الاغاني الراكده
اطربنا في هذا الصباح
حاضر ايش تبون والله نبي اللي تجود فيه
داعب الاوتار وانت كريم واحنا نستاهل
[موسيقى]
ولدنا على غلام صانع يمني حضرمي
من المحبه غير الشوق والحنين
ما خسرت الا وجودك
ما خسرت الا
وجود وضحكته
[موسيقى]
ما خسرته الا وجودي ضحكتي
محزن
هذه عيوني ما تبي وجهي حزين
[موسيقى]
كل ما تنزل دم
وعي كل ما تنزل
دموعي
تبتسم
كل ما
[موسيقى]
تسيبني
قدرت تسمع
قلبي
[موسيقى]
كتر ما احبك سنين
علقت الدنيا في بالك
[موسيقى]
حبه ماله رزق
كان يسال كل ليله
وينك واخرك
[موسيقى]
وانسى لكن ما نسال
كان
يسالكو ليله وينك واخرك
كنت اقول له بكره يرجع
وانسى لكن ما
ننسى وما خذيت من المحبه
غير شوقي والحنين
ما خسرت الا وجودي
ما خسرت
اله وجودي
وضحكتي ونور المسا
ما خسرت
ضحكتي ونور
يعني عنا دقيقه واحده بس حبيت اني اسالك
قبل ما نختم بانه هل باعتقادك الاغنيه
اليمنيه ما زالت محافظه على جمال الكلمه
وعمق معناها يعني مثل برايي على الاقل
كثير من الاغاني الخليجيه ما زالت تحافظ
على ذلك اليمن ايضا
يمكن
الاشكاليات او المشاكل الاخيره اللي صايره
في اليمن هي اللي اخرت الاغنيه اليمنيه
ولكن ما زال موجود الشعراء الجميلين
والملحنين الجميلين والفنانين ايضا
الجميلين
طيب
خليه اسال عن طلال مداح
ابو بكر سالم محمد عبده ما الذي يعنون
لعبود خواجه كل واحد منهم محطه
بسرعه
اكيد طلال مداح
فنان عظيم وكلنا تلمذنا على يعني مدرسته
البعض يعني لم ترتبط تربطنا علاقه بهم
ولكن تتلمذنا على مدرستهم ابو بكر سالم
تربطني علاقه اسريه وشخصيه يعني كبيره
والدي ابو بكر سالم واستفدت منه كثير ايضا
مدرسه وتعلمت منها الكثير الاستاذ محمد
عبده لا شك انه مدرسه واسطوره الله يحفظها
ويعطيه الصحه والعافيه يا رب ان شاء الله
عسى الله يعطيك ايضا الصحه والعافيه
والسعاده يا عبود وننتظر جديدك دائما
وهالمره بنصور وتكون عندنا هنا نسمعك لايف
شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد
من الانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات